let's say that you've had repeated
fights with your wife about how domestic
duties are going to be arranged among
around meal time and you believe me
you're gonna have those fights and so
and so what's happening is that
mealtimes are unpleasant because there's
a war for power going on in the kitchen
right and so then you think one day well
you're gonna you know note that and
you're going to do an archeological
investigation and find out just what the
hell is going on and so you start
unpacking the fact that mealtimes are
not pleasant and so what's in that
little thing that you're unpacking that
package well the entire power dynamic
between men and women in the modern
world is inside that dispute and you
might find that part of the reason that
your wife is upset about the way that
mealtimes are arranged because is
because her grandmother was beat by her
grandfather and that's playing a role in
it played a role in determining her
unconscious expectations and that's
pathologizing one of the day to day
rituals in the house and if you're gonna
unpack that you're gonna have to unpack
all of that into you take a little
monster and you decompose it you find
out it's a Hydra it's got 50 heads and
then you have to work through every
single one of those it's really really
difficult and so it's a container that
contains everything but the thing is if
you unpack it successfully let's say and
you deal with it
you go see eight a consensus then all of
a sudden you get you get peace say
around your mealtimes which is a major
accomplishment man because you have to
eat three times a day and it's the
center of the household and all of that
so but the thing is is that often when
you're especially in the context of an
intimate relationship things will emerge
that produced discontinuities and the
question is what should your attitude
towards that discontinuity be well you
can punish the person for manifesting
the discontinuity that's the tyrannical
aspect or you can let it take the whole
thing apart and that will happen I mean
that's often how relationships end is
that a discontinuity emerges and people
get into it and
things go sideways so badly that the
whole relationship descends into chaos
and people bail out of it and so it so
it's no wonder that people want to
ignore it and it's also no wonder that
they want to tyrannize it it's like quit
bothering me with that well possibly but
probably not and also if my attitude
towards you is quit bothering me with
that your attitude towards me when I
have the same sort of problem in Reverse
is going to be exactly the same and so
we're not going to get anywhere with it